foreign
[Applause]
s it's time for who knew don't spew
Ross can you even believe this moment is
happening no fun keeping it together
don't I look like I'm not freaking out
inside hello Michelle Obama okay so
here's how it's gonna work I'm gonna ask
you general trivia questions you're
going to answer them using a white card
they're not easy but you can do it now
for every wrong answer you're going to
take a step closer to this box whoever
gets here first is gonna have to eat
your worst nightmare now you don't like
Truffles and you don't like beets right
are you ready to see what's under the
box
reveal it
all right
oh my God so Drew on your side you're
going to see toast drizzled with truffle
oil truffle salt
house cheese truffle honey finished with
uh freshly shaved truffles okay we
doubled down Mrs Obama you have roast
beets on a bed of beet noodles steam
beets and beet puree
foreign
by the way I can smell the truffles well
there's a chance you won't have to eat
this okay okay because you know all you
have to do is answer these questions
right and you're not just playing for
yourself our audience has a chance to
win a not so nasty prize Mrs Obama
you're gonna be playing for this side of
the audience right here
I'm sure you're gonna be playing for
this side of the audience right here
how are you as a gamer are you
competitive oh yeah yeah yes I like
you're you're gonna be fine around here
all right all right take your spots on
the X okay you ready yes okay let's do
it question number one what Netflix
original show had the most streaming
views in 2021. oh a lot of shows on
Netflix but one of them had 1.65 billion
views in the first four weeks it's
original to Netflix reveal your answers
Bridgerton you wrote Good gas Bridgerton
you wrote Outer Banks the answer is
squid games oh
which means you're both taking a step
towards your worst nightmare that
doesn't seem fair all right question
number two what do you call a cross
between a pug and a beagle
a Puggle you both said puggle you're
both correct
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here in New York city so how about
a Broadway question
what is the longest running Broadway
show of all time oh it just closed after
35 years are you stressing very stressed
very stressful all right well let's see
your answers reveal them now Lion King
great guess Drew says Phantom of the
Opera also a great guest
Phantom of the Opera is correct
[Applause]
okay Mrs Obama takes a step forward okay
all right ready next question dolly was
the first ever living creature to be
cloned what type of animal was Dolly
let's reveal our answers Mr Obama says
sheep sheep okay no one moves you got
that right
okay what is the name of the main court
at the U.S open oh
what is the name of the main court at
the U.S open let's reveal our answers is
it Arthur Arthur Ashe Stadium that's
what you say Drew says the holy cow I
don't know
the answer is the Arthur
state
so it all comes down to this good
[Music]
foreign